ciao a tutti l'idea di questo video
nasce dopo aver sentito l'ultima
proposta di legge per te bando
all'impegno sociale
passiamo subito all'argomento ma voi
avete mai fatto caso a quando stata
ristorante a quello che accade nei
tavoli vicino quando arriva il momento
del conto
ora come al solito ho notato che le
atlete la categoria di pagatori dei
conti si divide in due grandi categorie
la prima solo i pitagorici
non importa se sei una pigna caduta dal
pino più alto della cambogia
se non ha mai aperto il tuo libro di
fisica del liceo o se pensi che la
radice quadrata insieme al timone da
valeria nas è l'ingrediente della tisana
dell'eterna giovinezza ma con rivas il
momento di pagare questi tipi si
trasformano i matematici laureati con
100 e lode e bacio accademico è stato
mortale con benedizione di moira orfei
allora dal momento che ti ho assaggiato
il 17.9 per cento della mia insalata
aggiungendo la cucchiaiata torta al mio
dessert la patata al forno che ti sei
preso e il fatto che penso 300
centimetri di acqua in più di me direi
che devo calare dal mio punto 5 euro e
24 centesimi
quindi se cozza st pachino come beckham
stan luigi scalfaro il prodotto totale
che io devo pagare è direttamente
proporzionale alla percentuale che
cazzate sparate dei nostri politici
moltiplicate per il numero interventi
chirurgici a cui si è sottoposta maria
di pani meana alla quale va sottratta
però la la massa espresse militi del
cervello di fare evento echoes teniamo
pure un bello d'oro pietoso o poi ci
stai completo a posto quelli che punti
pagare sarebbero disposti a errori
per terra il tavolo e sfidasse una gara
di bocce incendiarie che poi che sale
boccia incendiare che ne so sono la band
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no è linea novara
no no è il settore che il conto vabbè
vogliamo andare avanti per molto
bruttezza pe no guardi davvero no no
questa volta pago io ora mi arrabbio se
l'ho scritta a casa mia se lo speedo
nell'immensità pago io no cioè no a me
la prendo davvero no mi dispiace ma
pagherò no questo è lo sono fuori questa
cosa numeri primo farete pare che ti
pare che uno pn ospite a casa il duello
tv non è facile quest'anno completamente
fastidiosa no è semplice ma non lo
capisce partigiano faccio una pazzia
commento qualcosa di insensato così
guarda è semplice guarda tranquillo
moresco e marzo qualcuno come che cosa
può interessare
devo pagarlo al buio o attento sotto
quale offendo se non mi fa pagare
gardner aprendo e mitchell concido
davanti a tutti non ti invito più
il conto prendo tutto quanto ci viene
più se non mi fa pagare se io non lo
scorso questo canale
e poi siamo faccio è no prendo un
bambino non si vende un gattino è così è
farmi pagare quel conto che quindi deve
immaginarsi cosa accadrebbe se tutto ciò
non avvenisse voglio dire voi ci
rimarresti mare della serie arriva il
cameriere mette il conto sul tavolo
tutti i tuffi per prenderlo per primo
per pagare è la persona che ti sta
davanti si controlla i denti del
giudizio sfruttando il potere
riflettente delle posate battendo sera
altamente di pagare cara si è sparsa
voce cosa ma è pure una settimana che
torni a scanno a casa mia cioè non è che
ti fa male mite le mani al portafogli
sicuramente maleducato una parte tua
lasciatelo dire alcott spicci ben il
latte scusi devo fare pure il signor
ematico lanciato come orso yoghi e matt
davis se tu fossi mio ospite non ti fai
toccare il portafoglio né mila per mezzo
secondo
buone s2 ospite in quella casa c'è in
mezzo alle montagne crollante in mezzo
alle carcasse morenti di di pecore in
newman time suo veramente superato il
limite questa è l'ultima volta che ti
vengo a trovare gil isoardi rete la più
grande delusione della mente resistenza
agganciarlo sganciano lo sgancio del
danaro
mi pare che uno che hanno ospitato da un
po amico vanno al ristorante per di più
ristoranti che questo tipo manca a
mangiare una pizza capito che devi pure
far scoccini sono cose
al mondo non le ho mai sentite sono
disgustati bravo bravo è bravo bravo
complimenti bravo dello sgancio ed un
leone in brutto pezzente figlio da
paritaria
[Musica]